bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
sud doorways ragazzi nuova serie horror
è passato un [ __ ] giorno dalla fine
di outlast e già siamo sulla nuova serie
horror così perché io non ne ho mai
abbastanza
comunque ragazzi prima di iniziare
volevo soltanto introdurre via videogame
per dire di che cosa si tratta per chi
non lo sapesse the doorway se uscito
ieri è uscito ieri 22 23 non so che
giorno è oggi quindi non lo so che john
era ieri comunque è uscito ieri
videogame ma se avete notato nel titolo
c'è scritto parte 2
praticamente gli sviluppatori mi avevano
dato la beta del gioco che consisteva
nel nei primi minuti di gioco
praticamente ero arrivato fino a questo
punto qua dove sono adesso crisi ragazzi
per chi non avesse ancora visto la parte
1 cricchi sulla notazione dove c'è
scritto parte 1 qui sopra il video
esattamente qui direi che possiamo
proseguire preso voti essere state
vedendo questo punto abbiate già visto
la parte 1 se no è una cosa po più o
meno inutile
ho finito il capitolo 1 ragazzi capitolo
2 l'auditorium vedo proprio l'ora di
prendermi spaventi sani e freschi
ragazzi proprio la cosa che non vedevo
mi sveglio la mattina questo desiderio
proprio cioè non cos'è lo siamo perfetto
loro idea di dove ci son finiti
ah beh quella lascia alla ragazzi noi
praticamente siamo entrati in una casa
che non era abbastanza abbandonata direi
che è questo questo è lucius malfoy ma
vabbè non è da di chi sia ma questo è il
padre di draco ma c'è una leva la kg non
so che cosa serve magari crolla tutto
ragazzi leva inutile l'unica utilità è
quella di strà cassar mi [ __ ]
comunque non sa che serve sta roba
e sono dora l'esploratrice mi figone
coni c'è qualcosa qui sotto
raga ho trovato ho trovato un passaggio
però non ci faccio caso sono troppo
grasso raga non ha idea di che cosa
fosse perfetto cos'è sta roba
ho trovato un ingranaggio non ha idea di
che cazzo mi riparo la macchina con
questo forse c'è qualcosa qui sotto non
ci riesco a passare però non idea di
come fare ma ora cosa importante che
l'abbiamo trovato non ho idea di che
cazzo serva sinceramente però qualcosa
di sicuro devo devo ammetterlo tipo non
lo so io ho trovato un inganno o
perfetto può vincere meccanico ragazzi
eva vige la giusta tutto caso mai così
pronto fa vj telefono di emergenza per
tutte le evenienze cazzo ragazzi riparo
ponti su richiesta un giorno volete
soffrire il servizio bene io ragazzi sta
gente non so chi cazzo si sa però del il
fatto che delle statue prendano vita non
è una bella cosa noi andiamo avanti
comunque ragazzi sto sto gioco è troppo
buio cioè ragazze se lo sono studiato
bene è un horror spettacolare un altro
ponte avrà o mi trasformo i superman o
non ne devi come cazzo ci possa cos'è
quello ad eva devo attivare qualche
ingranaggio per poter perfetto ragazzi
non è da lì che cazzo fare a devono
infilarli le chiavi più gente una
canzone trovo le chiavi che ne so io
cerchiamo ste chiavi prima di definire
ammazzati buongiorno lei lei stia
tranquillo non si muova da lì ragazzi
avviso acqua c'è una leva perfetto
questa chi inutile non ho idea di che
cazzo abbia fatto ma qualcosa ho fatto
di sicuro perché non è che possono
essere tutte inutili ste leve ok
perfetto ragala cosa brutta visto ciò
che non c'è un cazzo di cose
io vado avanti a trovare pezzi che non
ai dati che con di come siano saltati
fuori comunque non facciamoci domanda
andiamo avanti così proprio non si ha
idea di che cazzo fare ciò non deve
essere una macchina del tempo un
qualcosa del genere ragazzi che cazzo
succede che cazzo è calmi ok perfetto
allora mi hanno chiuso dentro non era
non era esattamente quello che mi
aspettavo
[ __ ] adesso che siamo in una
camera che non era di che cazzo si
attiviamo st leva perché non ho altre
soluzioni bene ragazzi che cazzo ok è un
[ __ ] ascensore non so dove li sta
portando ma di sicuro più in basso di
prima e il che non è un sollievo stava
sta roba non serve a niente bene
già prima non vedevo un cazzo addio anno
bucano le bollette l'elettricità qui
sotto non ci avrei mai scommesso che
vorrei capire da che cazzo arrivano le
luci se non le dispiace vado dall'altra
parte anche perché non so che come ci
sono finito qui sotto
va beh noi scendiamo di qua raga io non
so ancora che cazzo ci sta a far east
opposto
sembra tutto enigmatico comunque ragazzi
lui non so se mio amico effettivamente
buongiorno senza buon nuovo non voglio
disturbarla mentre sta pensando non so
che sta ragionando sui miei prossimi
gameplay però coraggio buon uomo faccia
un atto di gentilezza mi di asta chiave
grazie ragazzi sono pingping in
confronto a stoke all osso filo a chiave
i ragazzi se lo sapevo passavo ali che
acqua di fianco e mi prendeva una sedia
non lo sapevo cazzo
cioè non prende non guardatevi così
porca [ __ ] negozi e ma sesto posto
affacciato chiesto anche per favore
uno ti chieda anche per favore renditi
conto ok calmo è calmo che non ti ho
fatto un cazzo calmo ragazzi
la chiave non so dove la messa ma l'ha
buttata da qualche parte
ok ok effettivamente sono diventate una
sottiletta kraft vieni brutto colosso
non hai mai visto famiglie giocare a
rugby a bastardo allora ragazzi devo
fare il giro perché sono questo mi fai
culo così la chiave la puntata suo
chiamero tutto quanto amico mio mi
spiace ce l'hai più piccolo di me come
cazzo mi ha preso allora porca [ __ ]
vediamo di far le cose come si deve
allora la chiave l'ho presa bastardo di
merda vabbè allora cerchiamo di aprire
sta roba aspetta che prendo la chiave
lei prima carico l'affare veloce ok ha
trovato qualcosa non so che cos'è ma
prendiamo e mettiamolo in tasca
probabilmente un coupon per mangiare
all'autogrill macori via per caso ok
ragazza l'ho fatta non è da juve cazzo
sia finito il tizio si è sbarrata la
strada perfetto meglio così e a parte
quello poi non so dove andare quindi
spero che l'ascensore funzioni di nuovo
adesso fatemi aprì anche sta roba che
non so che cosa ci sia un po a rettore
cazzo ce l'avevo già questo qualcuno fa
uno scambio perché è un doppione porca
[ __ ] ma è qui da solo non ce la farei
era meglio se mi facevo i cazzi miei
forse ho capito ragazzi no aspettate per
sé
ragazzi fa vj l'aggiustatutto raga anche
gli ascensori un ponte un ascensore che
cazzo in sto gioco in cinque minuti
aggiustato due cose ragazzi
lo scopo di sto gioco probabilmente
aggiustare roba nelle catacombe o cose
del genere va bene sono soddisfattissimo
e grazie mille anche me lo riprendo
questo è anche se non ho idea di che
cazzo sia servito perché siamo ancora
noi siamo secondo erano prima serie c
alla fine ci ho guadagnato una cazzo di
chiave penso debba metterla
no infatti non serve un cazzo ragazzi ho
trovato una chiave che però non serve
una beata mica forse questo fantastico a
una cosa è servita cioè non sapete non
so di preciso che cosa ho fatto prova
cosa ho fatto o che sia si è alzata una
colonna ne mancano due che cazzo devi
provare scusa ma a questo quale ho
trovato prima perfetto ragazzi di marca
1 non ho idea di che cosa se fosse
fusibile rotto sto trovando pezzi che
non sono anch'io come mi sto trovando ma
va bene perfetto ragazzi ci siamo
tenetevi pronti l'ultima colonna in
alzata aspettate un attimo che devo
vedere ci sono due strade quello che mi
chiedevo prima cioè non so dove devo
andare per primo ho l'imbarazzo della
scelta proprio cioè non vedo l'ora
il che non è un altro ascensore ragazzi
ma poche tanto questo mi serve per
andarvi sotto quindi non lo tocco e dai
andiamo ragazzi non so dove stiamo
andando sempre più in basso ovviamente
cioè finiamo veramente nel centro della
terra ma va bene noi possiamo c'è una
fantasia si posi ragazzi che mi lasciano
allibito cazzo ci sono troppo belli
vabbè siamo siamo dato anche parte
madonna che luci
ma non sarà mica troppo stima zio stai
calmo che arrivando schiaffi e di
tenersela parte quella lancia se non sai
dove te la metto immagina zio madonna
che ombra brutta dopo non ho idea di che
cosa mi rappresenti sto tizio ma noi
andiamo avanti di quei ragazzi prima o
poi devo cos'è buongiorno e la camera
dei segreti questa se sente troppo figo
mio dio vale ragazzi io io vado avanti
non cagate fa vj che passa tranquillo
non voglio recari disturba nessuno
continuato a dormire tranquilli bravi
così socievoli comunque pensavo molto
peggio cioè almeno non mi sono saltati
addosso brutalmente ragazzi dove siamo
finiti non va bene noi chiediamo leve a
caso mica non succede qualcosa perfetto
raga manca l'ultimo e con questo ci
dovrebbero essere tutti compreso quello
lì dentro allora adesso non so se si
apre la roba fosse prima devo tirare
l'avevano infatti mi sa che devo dire
alla leva prima così non è successo un
cazzo fantastico e non era esattamente
quello che mi aspettavo
mi serve anche questo non lo so ragazzi
hanno questo serve per ricaricare le
batterie ma che cazzo io ho ancora
capito allora credo che questa sia
l'ultima
ok mi serve per aprire la roba p o le
ragazze ci siamo riporato anche una
statua non so che cosa cazzo mi serva
però qualcosa è servito di sicuro che
che bella tra l'altro ragazzino magari
che cosa cazzo abbiamo fatto siamo nelle
miniere di moria di sicuro ho fatto
casino quindi qualcosa succederà prima o
poi si sono accese le luci ragazzini un
generatore chi cazzo vi ho detto di
muovervi ok fermi fermi le allora
facciamo così io
siete bravi a giocare perché io a uno
due tre stella non ho mai visto gente
così brava allora aspettate un attimo
uno due tre stella
sì però dovete muovervi il gioco
consiste nell'arrivare va bene non fa
niente non è non importa basta che state
fermi così il gioco consiste nel non
muoversi vi ricordo a tutti quanti
quindi state fermi pupa state fermi
tutti quanti bravi così tu che cazzo
guardi e ragazzi sono veramente
bellissimi minchia questo che
contorsionista ok se chiuso la porta io
io ci ho messo tutta la buona volontà ma
se non avete voglia di giocare e fate il
cazzo che volete comunque ragazzi
dobbiamo uscire liquidi qualche modo c'è
qualche porta sì sì perfetto sia aperta
non so come che accoglienza raga
fantastico c'è l'importante che siano
rimasti fermi ed io dico tegola lancia
si provi a te beh lì visse dal fermo
perché poi sai dove the line per quella
roba lì ok ok ok mi sa che non ha capito
il discorso ragazzi allora la lancia la
devi mettere nel capro anzi a lui che
già piegato ok perché non serve a nulla
mette alla media ma non ce la fate
qualcosa di meglio da fare ti può andare
al bowling o fare altre puttanate da
amici invece che rompere il cazzo verve
di testa gente minchia che rispetto
andato sotto le scarpe ragazzi no no
figlio di tua madre ragazzi vabbè basta
io tento di fare lo slalom
se riesco bene sennò amen ci ho provato
vabbè togliti piuttosto non so devo
passare mustapha vj ragazzi sto facendo
non so come ma ci sto facendo di salto
tipo mio dio favre un atleta olimpionico
va bene ce l'ho fatto sì grazie mille
arrivederci brutti stronzi
ok non so come ho fatto ragazzi non mi
chiedete ma ce l'ho fatta b e basta ti
prego no quanto dovete rompere il cazzo
[Musica]
vabbè ragazze la gente non è un cazzo
socievoli sto gioco penso che l'abbiamo
capito tutti importante ragazzi che è
che si è riusciti a scappare a quel
posto di merda non ho idea di che cosa
ci sia qui perfetto a roma che siamo
tornati volevano prima ho girato una
leva a caso non solo ai di cazzo fatto
ragazzi bene così ci siamo dopo secoli
di ton
perché io l'ho tirato anche all'inizio
quella ciao zeus senti zio io l'ho
tirata anche all'inizio con la leva
linea è però non ha funzionato
all'inizio c'è come funziona solo quando
decidi tu
va bè ragazzi non voglia di che cazzo
sia successo comunque vediamo chi
raggira scomposto prima di cadere
ammazzati da qualche parte ora gara
aggiungiamo lo zio james e tu che tocchi
pacco agli altri kick it era chi sa da
chi ti ha dato il permesso di toccare
parco la gente maniaco ragazzi qua c'è
gente veramente l'osca cioè ve lo dico è
già una cosa veramente brutta
io io non so se è tutta colpa di zeus lì
sopra come come si sa le qua come
l'ascensore 3.0 qui piano 4 grazie
perfetto e meglio più tecnologico dei
degli ascensori di new york ragazzi
buongiorno
non voglio assolutamente disturbarti
romperti cazzo volevo soltanto dirti che
c'è un tizio che tocca la sotto allora
mi chiamò per farmi incazzare 30
chiariamoci e vediamo di capirci io sono
fa vigenti va bè ragazzi concludo qui il
primo episodio ovviamente essendo il
primo in teoria il secondo ma vabbè
essendo all'inizio del gioco ancora non
siamo entrati nel vivo dell'horror ton
curiosissimo di coltivarlo per vedere
che diavolo esce fuori comunque ragazzi
se è vito è piaciuto come al solito ha
sciolto un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siano
quelli siti iscrivetevi riuscì vediamo
un prossimo vino bei ragazzi